hopefully everyone can join on time
good morning and welcome to this free
webinar
in this session we will discuss
our upcoming training program called
omics logic data science
and the online research opportunities
for students faculty and industry
professionals
that you can leverage to apply
bioinformatics to complex and
fascinating data sets
demonstrating your data science skills
and learning about biology
different diseases and the treatments
that are coming out
from the data that we have about these
biological conditions
so i'm excited to welcome you to this
free webinar again we're just going to
start
here in just a couple more minutes as
everybody is just joining right now
and i'm looking forward to also
interacting with you and getting to know
all of you hoping that you will attend
the full program that will start
on august 3rd
now i know that for some of you this is
not morning this is actually evening
so we're here in new orleans and it's
morning time for us and this recording
of this webinar is also going to be
available
for future reference
okay so for those joining us for the
first time my name is ilya brodsky i'm
the co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our vision here at pine biotech is to
enhance human health and well-being
by enabling biological research and
discovery with relevant data
solutions and expert support our mission
is to simplify bioinformatics and
advanced research through our modular
and intuitive multi armaments analysis
platform
powered by human experience and
artificial intelligence
you can read more about us at pine dash
biotech.com
but what our company does is we offer
training research support
and big data analytics tools designed
for research and biomedical discovery
our mission is to support cutting-edge
research projects and solve big data
challenges by developing
innovative solutions that are easy to
use and
to provide training to use them
effectively and
help scientists arrive at sound and
reproducible results
i am honored to have been working with a
team that collectively have an amazing
amount of experience in this area
including the other co-founders of the
company dr alfred tauber
and dr lena brodsky they come from a
medical background with expertise in
oncology immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation
as long as as well as bioinformatics and
biostatistics
dr tauber has a long-standing
recognition for his generous support of
many international projects and research
activities and one of these projects is
the establishment of the talbot
bioinformatics research center
which is developing the core technology
upon which our platform is based
dr lena brodsky is the director of the
talbot bioinformatics research center
and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics has numerous publications
on bioinformatics algorithms
and has developed a number of different
novel algorithmic approaches
that are specific to different types of
biomedical data analysis
these have been widely used in basic and
translational research in biotechnology
pharmaceutical r
d agriculture and basic research
well what we will discuss today is also
a result of hard work
by some of the people mentioned here on
the left julia pinoff who is an expert
bioinformatician has helped prepare many
of the materials we will use
avi ttyevsky who is a computer scientist
and leads the development of the tbionfo
platform that we will leverage
mohit mazumder who is in charge of
business development for pine biotech
joshua mckindle who maintains the
educational web portal
we will leverage and beeps abyss was our
online community manager
and support specialist so i'm sure that
many of you already had the chance to
interact with already
of course there are many more on our
team and that i simply do not have time
to mention specifically in this short
period of time
but it's really a great team that is all
committed
to making bioinformatics more accessible
over the past several years we have
conducted a number of programs
for thousands of participants both
online
and at a variety of university campuses
around the world
we have been working with faculty
researchers and students
to build a collection of essential
bioinformatics training modules
that cover the important omics data
types methods of analysis
and illustrations that demonstrate
applications of bioinformatics
to various life science domains so the
online omixlogic programs are built on
this foundation
as in all of our programs this upcoming
omics logic data science program
will give you access to all of our
online training resources
and include special daily meetings for
one and a half hours each day
that will provide a hands-on experience
and interactive learning sessions that
are much different from
what you typically get from online
courses
the program is a combination of
interactive sessions
asynchronous coursework coding
assignments
and support from our team that will be
available to assist you
and help you overcome any technical
challenges
that you might face over the course of
the program
you will get a chance to build a
personal profile
completing online coursework answering
quiz questions
completing assignments and gaining new
badges to demonstrate your
accomplishment
the point system is based on detailed
data that reflects participant activity
including time spent and modules and
quizzes different grades
practical analysis evaluation and points
for completing coding challenges
upon completing the program requirements
of participation and minimum course
completion you receive a certificate of
participation that you can always use on
your resume
linking to a profile that also shows all
of your achievements over time
for those that decide to continue and
work on a project of their own
for the duration of the program you will
also gain personal feedback from an
expert
in the field that we will match you with
when the project
is complete you will receive a special
certificate of
excellence that's why our previous
program participants
rank the onyx logic programs at the top
based on program interactivity personal
feedback
support and the quality of projects that
you will be able to achieve
leveraging the resources that are made
available as a part of this program
so let me briefly speak about the omics
logic data science
program what is it all about and what
are you
going to expect to get out of this
program
let's start from the beginning what is
data science and how is it related
to biomedical or omix data the truth is
is that data science is a recent term
that is used to represent a variety of
different things
statistics computer science and a
variety of different applications
in different domains for example data
science could mean
preparing data for analysis when you
extract data from financial markets
it could also mean that you're analyzing
advertising revenue
and different audiences or preparing
sentiment analysis when you analyze
social media data when we talk about
biomedical data that is the domain
knowledge that you must have
to be able to apply effectively computer
science and statistics principles
to extract knowledge or inference
from the data that you have access to so
when we talk about
data science in the context of biology
that
is typically or traditionally has been
referred to
as bioinformatics bioinformatics in
itself
is also a diverse field bioinformatics
covers
collection of data annotation of data
access to different types of data
as well as the tools to analyze
visualize
and interpret this data so we are going
to focus on this program specifically
on the omixlogic data science portion of
bioinformatics
so we'll talk about briefly different
types of omics data
formats and challenges associated with
some of the new types of data that are
being that are becoming more and more
widely accessible
we're going to talk about how to use
exploratory data analysis to prepare the
data
appropriately for the different types of
analysis for downstream
analysis and how you can use different
types of statistical properties of the
data to understand
whether you can you have to normalize it
and
remove outliers we'll also cover a topic
that has been
becoming more and more popular and
interesting in a variety of domains
called machine learning now machine
learning is
a term that has been around since the
1950s
and has really transformed our ability
to deal with big data
surprisingly in biomedical data or
biological data new technologies called
high throughput technologies have really
made big data problems central to
discovery
and application of data analysis in this
field
so we'll talk about machine learning
different types of machine learning and
discuss the specific methods of analysis
and interpretation
because ultimately the goal of this
program is to help link
the raw sources of data to the different
tools and methods
of processing analysis visualization
and to help make scientific sound
and logical interpretation of the
outputs from these different methods
so in the program we have combined a
number of
interactive sessions that we will
conduct
for an hour and a half each day over the
course of two weeks
a total of 10 different sessions where
you will be able to ask
questions we will introduce topics and
we will also guide you
to complete specific self-guided study
materials that
will expand on the topics that we don't
have time to cover
in these interactive sessions in the
self-guided study materials we will
suggest
some study materials for you to complete
before our next session
but we realize that the time to go in
depth into each step of analysis will
take
a lot of time so we will offer you
additional time at the end of the
program to
complete some of these resources on your
own self-guided time
we'll also do practical assignments
these include big data
processing pipelines as well as coding
assignments
in both r and python so let me briefly
speak about some of these in greater
detail
an important application in biomedical
research for machine learning
has been in both clinical and pharma and
biotech
as well as the practical research or the
basic research applications
and so we'll talk about these starting
from the general logic
which helps us understand the objective
the problem
that is there for us to solve
and then we'll talk about examples where
some of the machine learning tools and
data science principles
have been used effectively to find
interesting insights
about these problems that touch every
one of us
now it's important to understand these
challenges and problems
in industry and both research because
they apply
to anyone involved in the life science
research and application and when i mean
everyone i mean those that are in the
lab
so lab technicians that are generating
more and hopefully better data
that need to understand how this data is
utilized i'm talking about those that
are going to develop new data analysis
tools
and integration which is a huge
challenge right now in biomedical
research
as well as those that have to make
decisions based on some of the
tools models and data sets that are
available
so we're really talking about
bioinformatics
or biology as a data science that is
applicable
for all of these categories of
participants
let me talk about some of these
different topics in greater detail
so omics logic data science program
will start on august 3rd next week
on monday each day for an hour and a
half we will meet
together and we will discuss a variety
of topics
these are divided into two different
weeks the
first week is going to be dedicated to
data preparation
understanding the different types of
omics data and their properties
these are associated with big data
challenges and opportunities
and they require effective cleaning
loading and processing of data
you also have to know how to explore
this data quickly
using statistical assessment to
understand outliers and normalize your
data preparing it
for the specific types of analysis that
we will cover in week two
in the week two we will talk about
different types of
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
now it's a fascinating topic that we'll
touch on a little bit
in in detail today but we will talk
about it
from first a high level where we have
the two different categories of
supervised and supervised
machine learning we'll talk about the
models that are available
and how to train and fine-tune those
models
and we'll also talk about evaluation of
their accuracy
and how to make them applicable to
a more general application or project
and we'll also talk about production
quality so when we talk about production
we're actually trying to solve real
challenges so we'll provide a few
examples
of how they are applied in the real
world
so when we talk about data processing
we're really talking about
different data formats that are really
changing as a result of a variety of
different high throughput omics
technologies and they require
a combination of methods that are
combined together
in a sequential way forming what we call
bioinformatics pipelines
for example when we talk about different
types of omix technologies we're really
talking about
technologies like next generation
sequencing mass spectroscopy
different types of structural data and
each type of these data sets could be
fine-tuned
to study different topics for example we
can study
variation at the genomic level mutations
we can study methylation
which will allow us to understand the
structure of chromatin and how it
changes
gene expression we can also talk about
proteins that are being extract
expressed and how they interact with
each other protein protein interactions
or even study the microbiome the variety
of
small microorganisms that
can shape together as a community our
ability to
process different types of foods or
react to different types of
environmental
stresses and challenges so we'll spend
the first part of the program
talking about these different types of
data and how they are processed how do
we turn them from
raw data a raw direct output from that
machine from the technical instrument
that produces raw data
into what we call structured data
after that we will introduce our big
data analysis
multi-omics platform that you will have
access to
where you can analyze these data sets
without
having to have extreme high performance
computing resources
on your own typically in a production
environment
you would design a pipeline and then
apply this pipeline to a variety of
different data sets
utilizing a predefined space and
computational resources so that's
exactly what this platform provides
now you will also discover that as you
learn about these pipelines you actually
get to understand the logic of this
analysis and the logic of this analysis
is reinforced by color-coded maps
explained methods with references to
in-depth review
and research articles a variety of input
and output formats that allow us to both
visualize the data and understand how
this data is associated with different
phenotypes
and also is a guided process so it
eliminates
a lot of the mistakes that people
typically make
when they first start building those
pipelines
now as a result you also get to
understand what reproducible workflows
really are so that you can take that
further
and apply that logic to a variety of
problems that you will face
in the future now behind each one of
these methods
is a piece of code a script
and so as we look at these different
steps we'll take
a few of those examples and dig deeper
to understand
how does it actually work and what
stands behind
each one of these buttons then we'll
also talk about data visualization and
normalization
so an important part of working with
these types of data sets is
understanding
what they represent and when we say what
they represent
because we have so many different
indicators for example over 20 000 genes
or over 3.2 billion base pairs in the
human genome
we really have to understand what they
speak about
what they can tell us about a variety of
different conditions
and so when we do that we have a number
of coding challenges that will help us
understand
how you can apply best practices
in both r and python to visualize this
data
and make that visualization more
impactful
for example in our practice example
examples you will see how you can select
an example of a specific type of a
visualization
learn about the code and as you learn
about the code and the outputs
you then get access to try yourself how
to
go through this code change some of the
settings
and in a step-by-step fashion develop an
understanding
of what the code does at each part and
then
how does it produce some of these
visualizations so by
changing some of this code and by
practicing in different environments for
example in
r and in python you will really start
understanding
what are the benefits of using some of
this technology
so we'll also see how in the future
as you use some of these methods you
will be able to
work with some of this information
inside not only on our omixlogic code
platform but also as you download the
code that you've produced on the
platform
and then modifying it on your computer
so that you can also take that away
from the program we'll also show
how some of these apply in biomedical
research so we'll talk about different
examples that you can start playing
around with different types of data
for example for cancer diagnostics and
an
understanding of cancer biology or an
understanding of
single cell data and tissue composition
how you can also study the microbiome
and different types of infections
at the genomic level or at the diversity
level
so ultimately when we say projects and
example data sets we actually mean
taking publications from
cutting edge research articles and
journals
and breaking those down in terms of what
the authors
did where did they find the data what
type of data it was
what kinds of methods they applied to
that data and ultimately
what is the use the practical
application of the type of analysis that
they performed
when we move on to week two we'll start
talking about
data mining and classification
so first about data mining when we have
big data sets it's important to
understand how these big data sets
can be very complex once they are
taken as a whole and we have specific
methods
that can allow us to identify patterns
in these complex data sets
by using data dimensionality reduction
and clustering so we'll talk about how
when you have your source data right and
the source data is
unlabeled you just have a number of
samples you can apply
a variety of different algorithms to
really understand what
is in the data in terms of patterns and
these algorithms
give us novel information so this new
information that we get out of these
algorithms is the association or
identification which group they belong
to
so we'll talk about a variety of these
algorithms
including different types of clustering
principle component analysis
and other types of dimensionality
reduction techniques that
apply to different types of data
differently
these will be both a high level overview
that will provide with clear explanation
of
why and when and how to use some of
these methods and for what purpose like
pca for data exploration visualization
and some of the considerations that you
need to have and that really make a
difference
when you try to apply these different
types of data sets
when we talk about clustering we'll
actually talk about the specific process
of going from bottom up or top-down
approaches
how do they differ what kind of
information do they provide
and how can we apply them to a variety
of these different problems
we'll start from an intuitive
user-friendly
interface well all you have to do is
upload your data
start your process and then understand
what are the specific
settings of each algorithm so when we
talk about these specific
settings we can try to apply different
types of settings change those
parameters
and see what are the outputs but then we
also have to learn
about the specific linkages distances
expected counts and what does that mean
that the data is being transposed when
we actually
input so we'll go a little bit deeper to
understand
how the different aspects of linkage and
distance
can help us understand what do we
actually mean
when we deal with data right because
this is not going to be
distance in a three-dimensional space
between
objects this is going to be distance in
a multi-dimensional space in a matrix
and so all of these different methods of
evaluating
linkages and distances will play a role
in what we ultimately get as a result so
when we
analyze our results we'll actually look
at visual representation
and link how the different settings that
we put
into the method give us different types
of outputs
we'll also see the relationship between
visualization of one type of data
and visualization of the same data in
terms of
how much information it provides because
the objective
of the analysis and matching analysis
visualization
is to really provide us insights into
in-depth
biological and biomedical problems for
example
we'll take a look at the cancer genome
atlas
that provides us multi-omics data sets
about a variety of different types of
cancers
where we can start realizing what are
the important factors
about tissue specialization as well as
cancer processes that we would like to
study
using some of these analytical tools now
from a data science perspective
we'll also see how some of these
different types of methods
are applicable not only for a output
that gives us a new group or an idea
about what the data structure is it is
also a very useful tool
for data visualization so we'll see how
some of these examples
really are great examples to improve our
visualization techniques
and to interpret the data that we have
in a much better way
now after we talk about dimensionality
reduction in clustering
we'll talk about classification machine
learning
is typically referred to two types of
problems
classification or prediction of a
specific
class based on label data as well as
regression
and so regression is a prediction of
your next
output from a continuous data set and we
won't as much focus on regression but we
will focus on classification
so in classification we will talk about
two specific
sub sets or sub problems which is
prediction itself and feature selection
supervised machine learning is a process
when we
take source data and are able to
label that data to prepare a training
data set
which is then used to train an algorithm
or a machine a
computer to be able to predict
what it learned from the training data
set on some test data
now the magic of making the training
data set representative of a problem
that we're actually interested in
and then having the right set of test
and validation data
is critical to making sure that your
model is going to be effective
and is going to be able to adapt to
unexpected types of challenges that
it will face in the real world so we'll
call it a black box for now
but this black box has a name and each
one of these algorithms that we put in
the black box will approach the problem
a little bit differently
so when we are able to offer a number of
different
examples a number of different project
data sets
that have real world implications about
treatment
about diagnostics about selecting a
specific type of an approach to treat a
patient
we will see how these different
algorithms actually work
and so when we look at the output and
we're able to
understand the output that this
algorithm provides us with
we'll also be able to evaluate both the
accuracy
and the feature significance of our data
set
so these are very useful tools that
in the context of machine learning
provide us with
an additional insight into how we can
start
working with the data sets these
different types of methods
are organized by different types of
decision trees
discriminant analyses or support vector
machines and so we'll take an example
this will not be a comprehensive
overview of all of the possible methods
out there
but i think it will provide you with a
real clear understanding
of how different categories of methods
actually work
and what are some of the important
parameters for us to tune
when we try to apply these data sets to
a specific problem
for example we'll talk about random
forest and we'll talk about the problem
of
bagging and applying multiple decision
trees
to get a good prediction consistently
and also do feature selection as we go
through that
process we'll talk about how we can take
support vector machines
and modify the way that the support
vector machines deals with classes
also to give us an understanding of how
it can be
applied to different types of kernel
problems
different types of complex classes and
also
feature selection in the context of
support vector machines
so let me briefly explain what you will
do
after you learn about the conceptual
part of the program
and are able to apply some of these data
sets so some of these methods
to a real data set
so when i talk about this code platform
i am talking about a specific number of
tools
that we have designed to support your
learning process
so first when you get to start the
program you will actually
register on the platform register
for the program so let me show you
briefly
what i mean on the platform as i
mentioned before there's a variety of
different resources starting from
a synchronous coursework to the set
to the sessions that we will have as an
interactive session and once you join
this program and register for membership
you will have access to all of these
upcoming sessions
in each one of these sessions we will
introduce a particular topic
and you will be able to ask questions
and get support through the forum that
is monitored daily
and where we can provide you with
additional information about all of
these different methods and data sets
that we are covering
you will also get access to coursework
in the coursework you will get
much more in-depth explanation of the
different topics that we cover
in the program and have practical
project examples that you can practice
on
you will be able to monitor your own
progress
by looking at what you have completed
where you have left off
and tracking the points that you get as
a result of
each one of your activity you will also
get
personal feedback on the assignments
that you submit
inside the courses there are assignments
that you will complete
and those assignments will be actually
evaluated by a person who will provide
you with comments
with additional links to resources that
you can study
or coursework that you can review to
make sure that the concept is clear
now some of these concepts are going to
be based
on coding and some of these are going to
be based
on an interactive platform that you can
actually use
without any coding right so we'll kind
of go from a high level overview
more and more in-depth and more and more
technical and depending on how technical
you want to get you can actually get
pretty far
by downloading eventually the scripts
onto your own system
and working directly in python or r
to make sure that you understand how all
that we do on the platform and we do in
the coding exercises
could be carried on without these tools
now an important part of these data sets
is that they are huge
when we're talking about transcriptomic
or genomic data literally every sample
has over gigabytes of data when you talk
about such data
having a coding environment is not
enough you have to have a lot of
ram you have to have a lot of cpu power
so
what we are trying to do is to level the
field for anyone
that does not know coding that does not
have those kinds of resources
to still be able to actually do real
research
so when you get access to the platform
you will be able to use first
demo pipelines that do not require
any kind of inputs and outputs but just
really
require for you to understand the logic
of the analysis
and once you understand the logic of the
analysis you can see the output
immediately without waiting for anything
to happen at all
for example in in this case we are
looking
at output of a genomic
visualization pipeline where we can see
how
individual reads from a particular data
set
are aligned to a reference genome right
and we can explore our data
at the read level in another example
when we want to do a event an estimation
of gene expression we can actually build
a combination
of other types of tools and those tools
will allow us to study
how high or low each gene
is expressed and as you can see when you
go through this process
you actually get to understand what each
step
does and quickly get an output
and we will talk about these outputs and
we'll talk about the different
biomedical challenges that these
problems
are illustrating how the bioinformatics
methods or
pipelines applied to this data set help
us understand
what is in these outputs now at the next
level
you will be able to go to the platform
and actually create these analyses
yourself on a project of your own
now you will have to make some decisions
about what type of data you're putting
in
and how will that data be processed
using the same tools that you've learned
about
in the coursework and in the demo
pipelines
after you run some of these you will see
that some of the results
will actually include outputs as
downloadable code so here for example
i will look at an example pipeline that
i ran
and you can see that one of the outputs
is a pack
in r i can take this package in r
and actually play around with the same
code understanding what it does
in these exercises or tutorials and then
playing around with them again using a
cloud environment
so we are offering two options on this
cloud
tutorial the first option
is guided coding tutorials so let's take
a look at an example
here we took the same code that was
in the output from the pipeline and we
are taking
a gene expression data set to understand
what can this gene expression data set
tell us
about the problem that we are studying
once we understand it
we go through a breakdown of the code we
understand what libraries are used
what how do we input the data what do we
actually do to plot the data
and to perform the analysis after that
you get to try it yourself
you actually can change the input data
set you can change the parameters
and you can run this data set to
understand what will
actually produce this runs
on our server so when it runs on our
server
you will see an output provided to you
just on the browser by running on the
server so for example here
i got the same results from this
principal component analysis
in a 3d view in
python however we do not offer a
a server to run your analysis in python
when you select the same
exercise in python you will be able to
actually
run this on your own computer now you'll
see the differences in code
and understand how it relates to solving
the same type of a challenge but in a
different coding language
but you will actually have to load all
of the information
in your browser so the next step
after you have completed your coding
challenge
you can download the full code and you
can actually go
into your own environment and start
playing around
with that code to make sure that you
understand how to set
your working environment your data sets
from your computer and make the output
save
into files now there are additional
benefits to that because you can
actually call
specific functions that can only work on
your computer
and not on the server that we provide
you so we hope that this process
is going to be effective for all of you
to go from
a high level overview of what we are
doing
in terms of the logic of analysis to see
the different
examples of projects to them to be able
to be further
into the code itself and eventually set
it up on your computer so
let me tell you what are some of the
coding exercises that we have prepared
for this program so we will talk about
different tools like differential gene
expression which really uses statistical
analysis
as well as some clustering to make
effective visualization of
differentially expressed genes
we'll talk about principle component
analysis
as a dimensionality reduction analysis
for these complex data sets like gene
expression
we'll talk about clustering and
different types of clustering like
k-means or hierarchical clustering
and we'll also talk about classification
the problem where we have to assign
classes to our data sets and then see
what types of methods
are giving us the best prediction also
evaluating
what is this prediction quality how
accurate is it
and how stable it is when we apply it to
a different validation data set
finally we'll talk about a variety of
different applications so i think what's
fascinating
in terms of data science for biomedical
data
is that you can quickly see
the application of these tools to very
important
and significant data sets these are not
data sets that
are about generating money these are not
data sets that are about social
sentiment
and interaction between people these are
data sets that
really explain the basis of diseases
different biological processes at the
subcellular level
and infection using examples from
pathogens that we're all painfully aware
of like covid19
so we really put a lot of effort into
preparing
project examples curated data sets
and specific guidance to give you a
background
before you jump into your analysis if
you've seen
like me any other types of examples on
data science and machine learning you
know that in each presentation
at least 30 minutes is dedicated to
explaining a data set
and unfortunately we get to use very
simple data sets
data sets that are actually about value
of homes
or square footage or pedals and and
different types of plants so i think
it's very important for us to hear
understand what types of challenges
we're going to be solving
so one example that we'll be using is
the application of machine learning
for prediction of survival for cancer
patients
over a time frame of about five to ten
years
so this is a huge challenge when you
look at a patient today
how can you actually predict will that
patient survive
will it have a recurrence of the same
disease what are their risk level what
are their chances of survival
and we'll talk about specific ways that
we can use this type of information
to make decisions about treatment
selection
we'll also talk about a novel type of
cancer therapy drugs
and these drugs have started to become
more and more popular because of their
effectiveness starting from a drug
called herceptin that was introduced in
the 1990s
so not so long ago and we'll talk about
the relationship
between the biological understanding
of how these different diseases occur
develop
and manifest in different patients and
what are the specific types of
indications that we can extract from big
data
that allow us to target those specific
pathways
we'll also talk about the application of
big data right so once we have a
collection of big data
how is that actually changing our
ability to
analyze a new patient that comes in
providing a much more accurate diagnosis
by assigning that patient to a
particular
class or group that we have already
previously studied
so we'll actually talk about a number of
different examples
like i mentioned before these examples
are both in the clinical domain
and in the pharma and biotechnology
domain
so in the clinical domain we'll talk
about examples of patient stratification
how we can group patients by risk
and what do we actually call risk how do
we know what their risk is
disease classification and diagnostic so
how do we know
what a disease is and how do these
machine learning tools
actually change our understanding of
disease and how they
actually affect today our ability to
diagnose diseases like cancer
or like individual types of infections
infections that have resistance to
specific treatments
or infections that are caused by
different pathogens
they are also applied to identification
of potential responders to therapy so we
can actually
study a patient today and predict what
is the most likely
course of treatment or combinations of
treatments
or what kinds of interactions we should
be aware of
to make sure that the treatment or the
therapy is effective
obviously in the basic research domain
the mechanisms of disease
onset and progression are critical
because ultimately
the machine learning model that we
designed has to be
easy to explain to someone that needs to
trust that machine learning model so a
big challenge with machine learning
is when the machine learning model
predicts something very obvious
if you tell a patient that they should
be taking this drug or another
you just have to say that you're a
doctor for that patient to trust you
somewhat but if you're talking to
doctors that have
years of experience and know that this
drug
and that drug have a similar mechanism
of action or they perform a similar
function when they metabolize
you actually have to convince them that
the machine learning prediction
that this drug should be used instead of
a drug that they're familiar with
you actually have to be able to explain
the model performance
and what features it actually is based
on
so that part of it is very critical for
machine learning adoption in the
clinical world
in farmland biotechnology as you all
know it takes
over seven years to bring a drug to
market so there are critical challenges
to making sure that the new drugs
that are discovered using accumulated
data from
thousands of patients in a variety of
conditions
are actually going to be effective and
they're going to be
used effectively when they are on the
market so to say
so there's a variety of challenges like
biomarker discovery
how do we understand based on molecular
features
which patients to treat with what drug
detection of toxicity at the in vitro
stage so before we start
testing this in humans how do we
actually understand
that a drug will not be toxic right how
do we eliminate the potential
of long-term toxicity for example side
effects that are related to
chronic heart conditions when we are
trying to
you know uh treat mild conditions uh
like inflammation in joints or something
like this right so how do we detect that
at an early stage
analysis of molecular mechanisms of a
drug action or target discovery
and also drug repurposing or
repositioning how do we actually
apply these tools to solve challenges
when we talk about known approved drugs
that
are known and studied potentially to
have
new indications or new applications to
new types of treatments
so i think very very important and very
practical applications that we can
try and apply these methods to now i
think the exciting part of it is to
actually
try and apply the methods that you will
learn
in this program two data sets where you
kind of know what the outcome would be
at first right so at first you can
really see
the outputs from your own analysis
and compare them to analysis that an
expert team has done
and once you know how that matches up
you can actually start applying those to
new types of questions so
a particular objective for these
programs for
us is to be able to
allow you to develop a new project idea
and we have a set of guidelines
that we have prepared that we think will
help you in that journey
so in fact i think that and bibs maybe
you can share this link also for the
participants
we have a guide on how to prepare your
own project so
as we talk about tools and the different
applications and the different example
data sets
how do you actually start developing
your own project
so again this project or this program
will consist of two weeks and in those
two weeks we will cover
a lot of ground to get you into this
domain of big data and
different types of tools to process
analyze visualize and interpret the data
sets
after the two weeks are over you will
have additional time
to work with our support on an
independent project
or on working on one of the projects
that we have prepared
as an example for you to learn from
now i want to conclude this with
some registration links that you can use
to complete your registration if you're
interested in this program
we have a process where you first fill
out a pre-registration link
and please put these links on
the chat if possible so
the pre-registration link and let me
actually go to this link
will get you to a page where you learn
about the program topics
you can also ask us questions obviously
in the session after i
complete we'll have some time about five
minutes
to come to answer any questions you
might have
and once you fill out this information
you send it to us
and our team actually reviews reviews
this information
and send you some additional information
on what to do if you would like to
register
who is this for and what is the best way
for you to use this program right so we
want to make sure that it's very clear
this program is designed specifically
for those that are
interested in big data is specifically
in
omics data applied to biomedical domain
and would like to go beyond kind of an
interactive high level bioinformatics
so they would like to get some coding
experience
as a result of this but it is not a
coding
workshop this is not a program to get
you to be proficient
in r or python we hope that you are
either already familiar with one of
these languages
or are committed enough to independently
pursue
additional help with getting proficient
in those languages we will simply not
have enough time
to do that in this program so but you
will get some experience
you will get an understanding of the
different methods and you'll be able to
interact with our team
to get help if you decide to go deeper
into one of these topics
okay so after you do this you actually
go
to you receive a link to complete your
registration
on the main program page now once you
complete this registration
you create a profile for yourself this
profile is where you start accumulating
points so i'll explain what this means
you can see here an example profile of
one of our participants you can see that
once they register and by the way the
registration itself is free and we also
have some free tools available for you
you will see that a person who has
registered will have to
create a profile where all of their
activity is accessible
so that we can track and address any
issues that come
up you will have a point system that
helps you
estimate how far along you are in this
process of learning
and you can also continue picking up
from different courses that you have
started before
continuing to make progress in this
course in those courses
and completing those now each
independent course
is either included in the program
or accessible for free or some of the
courses might not be a part of this
program so you'll have to see
which courses are actually accessible to
you in the program
and once you complete them you get
individual certificates for completing
those courses and they will also
be available right here under your
profile
after you do that you can continue to
go deeper into one of the projects that
we make accessible
so those projects will illustrate some
of those applications that i've already
covered
so that program is going to give you
a personal profile that personal profile
helps you start building some of that
points
some of those points and eventually the
top participants
are actually highlighted on our
leaderboard and so when we highlight
those participants on the leaderboard
we also tell their story we also explain
the projects that they have done
and i believe beeps you have a link um
to
uh some of those projects that have
previously been done by some of our
participants
um you know we're very encouraged and
proud to have received
you know a lot of very high quality
feedback
for these programs and so we think that
you know if
the fit is right for you and you are
ready to commit the time
and you know the resources in terms of
how much effort you'll have to put in to
actually make the most out of these
programs
you can get a lot from these different
programs
so i'm going to pause now
and i'm just going to make this open for
any questions that you might have
uh i'm going to um you know ask biepsa
and mohit to let me know if there are
any questions also on youtube
and i'll be able to continue in
addressing those questions
in the future
thank you india i think we have
addressed the questions on
youtube already so i would like to ask
if anyone has a question now we can
we can address those as well
okay and also i have a few questions
here
um that are unfortunately just on
um on zoom
okay so so there's a question i'm a
beginner with no prior knowledge of data
science still
i am able to understand it but it would
be better if you can explain some
technical terms for beginners
yeah so that would be the exact
objective of this program is to provide
you with an
overview of both the high level
logic and the specific terms that are
commonly used
we'll use that both as a general session
explanation of what these terms are but
also we'll see an example
um so so let me actually
show you an example
in a publication right so one of the
objectives for this is
for you to then be able to read a
publication
and really understand what they mean so
here you can see
how um we used least square support
vector machines and random forest
algorithms to identify
molecular features associated with
responses of a collection of 70 breast
cancer cell lines
to 90 experimental or approved
therapeutic agents
so you can see how right here in the
abstract which is just a few sentences
long
you already have to know what is least
square support vector machines what is
random forest algorithm
what are molecular features what how do
we find or establish
association how do we measure responses
what are these breast cancer cell lines
right so a lot of questions so we will
go into detail about each one of these
terms
okay so how much coding do you need to
know
the coding that you can start with zero
coding
experience literally if you have zero
coding experience and you start
you will quickly understand how some of
the methods
are done using coding now you can also
see
as a result of this program what type of
languages
are there and what kinds of
languages are best for what type of
application and what are some of the
considerations right so hopefully if you
don't know any coding
you'll be able to decide whether you
want to pursue
more specialized training in r or in
python right or you want to just do
a little bit of both right so that are
is
one of the outcomes that we hope to
achieve from this program
how long live sessions um
the live sessions are going to be one
and a half hours long
so they will include an overview of a
topic
a practical exercise that we will go
through together and make sure that
you're able to do that exercise
and then have some time for discussion
so if you have any questions
we're able to address those
okay um professor babu you're in vivo
pharmacologist
interest to take up the course but i
have knowledge on statistics but
beginner for data science and no
knowledge and coding or computer program
i think that's a perfect program for you
because it does require for you to
kind of understand logically what's
going on but then
with the computer programming or coding
you will get
guided um you know tutorials at first
then you will download them on your
computer will actually provide you
with some tools where you can start
practicing
so for software really will guide you
and maybe i'll give you an example here
if you go well eventually once you're
registered
you'll see here a clear
explanation of r and python
and how to set it up on your computer so
it's a real
interactive tutorial that you can go
through and if you have any questions
about this
you'll really see what we
i mean we'll we'll help you kind of
install all of this and and
basically you the only things that you
will need is to install
r and python on your computer
rstudio is preferable just to give you
an environment to work with
and then we'll go through some of these
in
in here which is an online platform you
don't need
anything to to run these examples
and we'll go from very basic on how to
load
uh you know manipulate and visualize
your data and it's going to start with
very simple
exercises okay so hopefully i answered
that question
what special alterations apps um so
again not really any apps all you would
need
is r r
studio and python to be installed on
your computer
okay great well thank you for attending
today
um hopefully uh biebs and mohit if you
could
post some of those links again for those
that are interested to review
some of the benefits of the program
again i think the program
is unique in the sense of online courses
it is not a typical
udemy or coursera course where you just
watch videos
and then do something on your own and
hope to get some feedback
this is a very guided program
and this program is going to be um you
know really
focused on the outcome so it is actually
in our interest
to get you to a place where you can
demonstrate your profile
and the projects that you have prepared
um as a real validation
of what you have learned right so you
can see some of the examples here and
some of the feedback from real
participants
we also have a page on some of the
project outcomes
um if you have some of those um
links we have a number of recent
projects that people have prepared in
our past programs and we run these
programs all the time
so there's really a variety of topics
that come up
in different in different programs
that we conduct
okay so thank you again for joining uh
this webinar
um we are going to be uh continuing to
um reach out to you with these links by
email so that you have them after this
webinar is over
and we welcome all of you to join come
monday
on august 3rd so we still have a few
days for any one of you that is
interested to complete your registration
please reach out to marketing
at pine.bio if you have any additional
questions
about the registration process thank you
for joining and
we'll see you again soon